drew Thompson really does love the
camera Khloe Kardashian is sharing her
beauty secrets of Vogue and her
one-year-old daughter was totally part
of the action and and we are going to
show you my makeup routine and some of
my skincare routine I want to put you
down so I can do this okay
say bye focus Khloe reveal secrets like
so what I like to do when I'm just
wanting light makeup I take my
moisturizer and I also like to put a
little bit of foundation with it trying
to create my own EB cream I would take
tips and tricks from my sisters and I
always remember Kim saying just make a
three and while all that is super
helpful the best part is that true can't
stop crashing Chloe's tutorial No okay
and then there's this moment she's
definitely my makeup assistant she loves
to hand me brushes she eats my sponges
you love pink q-tips okay thank you I
love you oh can I have a kiss give mom a
kiss
Chloe is such a hands-on mama oh my
goodness you look beautiful truthful and
she recently told ET being a mom is
priority number one following her split
with choose dad Tristan Thompson she's
not quite ready to date I love life well
besides you sorry sorry we're on a date
but um I just I'm really just enjoying
my life and my time with my baby and
family
it's Tito but when she is ready here's
what she's looking for
I've never really put that much pressure
on dating I'm just you know whoever you
are in a room with that you connect with
and there's chemistry then that's you
should date but I'm just not even in
that headspace but you never know what
will happen